bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 31
janvier quatre plus un pour leur
deuxième concert de la saison au théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
quatuor ardeo sera accompagné de vassy
l'ena céramiste serafimova ensembles
interpréteront notamment les quatre
saisons de vivaldi révélé il y a deux
ans au tremplin des voix sarah jeune
manu boiseau 18 ans se produit ce
vendredi à l'estaminet de magny les
hameaux
l'occasion de découvrir les premiers
titres de son de paix et claude nougaro
a disparu depuis 14 ans mais son
héritage est toujours là didier gustin
le prouve avec son dernier spectacle
as tu verras un hommage en 50 voix il
était à montigny-le-bretonneux mardi 30
janvier ardeo signifie je brûle en latin
cette intensité les quatre musiciennes
du quatuor ardeo en ont fait leur devise
jeudi 1er février
elles proposent leur deuxième concert de
la saison au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines yuko haras et
carole petitdemange deux des musiciennes
sont avec mon plateau mon jour
aujourd'hui alors ce 1er février il sera
notamment question de vivaldi narok et
kras exactement drogba à 8h alors
justement les quatre saisons de vivaldi
c'est sans doute l'un des morceaux fin
plusieurs des morceaux les plus connus
du répertoire classique vous vous
jouerez l'été et l'hiver on a encore des
choses à découvrir tout à fait surtout
que demain on va vous proposer une
version tout à fait originale puisque
c'est un arrangement qu'on fait avec le
bacille ena qui sera au marimba et au
vibraphone
donc ça donne tout à fait une autre
lumière
cette oeuvre des options 100 ans comme
ça comment est ce qu'on les joue comment
est-ce qu'on l'ait travail ou
on discute on cherche la joie de la
musique va céder dans les supers donc
oui on était veilleuse aussi et puis
c'est vrai qu'avec cette oeuvre
il ya vraiment une un guide puisque ils
valent il a écrit à travers à partir de
poèmes
donc à partir de l'interprétation du
poème on fait aussi une interprétation
personnelle de la musique ils n'ont que
y'a toujours c'est tout neuf en fait
comme musique puis il ya une telle
énergie dans cet hymne rock c'est
toujours lumineux vraiment beaucoup
d'énergie en fait et l'apport du marimba
qui est un une percussion en fait
renfort cette énergie donc il ya
vraiment un discours puisque tout ce qui
est un peu plus fluide devait être
plutôt portés par les cordes mais tout
ce qu'ils demandent un peu d'énergie un
petit peu plus bestial primitif là le
marimba apporteront une note totalement
extraordinaire
justement comment s'en est venu à
proposer havas elena serafimova de jouer
avec vous ce que vous normal et pourquoi
le marimba déjà prévus non non pas du
tout en fait ça fait ça faisait
longtemps que
on avait envie de monter un projet avec
vassy l'ena ça fait longtemps qu'on se
connaît on s'est rencontré sur un projet
qui s'appelle concerts de poche et on
devait jouer 1
une réduction de leur caisse de carmen
en fait donc nous on est l orchestre le
quatuor est l épée lafleur est question
et ça a vraiment été un coup de foudre
musical on avait il y avait vraiment une
alchimie en fait et quand on s'est dit
qu'on voulait faire un programme
voilà on a commencé à évoquer plusieurs
programmes possibles
et puis elle c'est quelque chose qui lui
tenait à coeur de faire cet arrangement
et puis c'est vrai que c'est assez
original et donc on s'est dit que pour
une entrée une mise en bouche dans le
concert c'était une belle âme mais
justement on a parlé du marimba
plusieurs reprises qu'est ce que c'est
exactement à quoi ça ressemble si vous
deviez le décrire j'ai vu que ça
ressemblerait un exil au fun africain
est ce que pas du tout ça pourrait être
ça c'est serré une sorte de grand piano
en bois les touches sont en bois duquel
elle utilise des baguettes alors
et très très méticuleuse avec le choix
de ses baguettes donc à l'a4 baguette il
y en a deux dans chaque main et donc
elles frappent ces grandes touches en
bois donc c'est comme une sorte de
clavier elle a un cahier un clavier
supérieure et un clavier intérieure et
donc avec ses baguettes elle
elle vient doucher ses touches ils font
des sons c'est vrai que ça évoque un peu
les îles on a un peu cette
cet habitant de voyages soit là c'est ça
tout à fait ça apporte une touche
colorée oui et c'est comme l'instant est
très grand et le bushveld ans et c'est
vraiment besoin de l on est presque une
spécialiste parce qu'elle est
percussionniste il a réussi un tel
instrument qu'elle est qu'elle aime
beaucoup l aime vraiment toutes les
percussions d'en parler encore tout à
l'heure lm spécialement le marimba c'est
vrai et c'est vrai comme disait ioukos
est très spectaculaire parce que c'était
cet instrument est très très grand en
fait et puis elle elle est quand même
assez petit donc il ya une forme de
danse quand elle saute d'un à voile
autres c'est très très très
spectaculaire alors on a parlé de vue
belle ville il n'y a pas que lui
parce que lors de vos concerts vous
mêler des pièces très célèbre et des
découvertes aussi pour le public
oui alors en fait c'est c'est toujours
quelque chose qui nous tient à coeur de
d'avoir des pièces peut être roulé le
public vient préparer à les entendre ils
viennent écouter une nouvelle version ou
une interprétation
et puis d'autres qui vont venir
découvrir en live en fait donc c'est
vrai que demain soit on va proposer
nawak
c'est une pièce vraiment écrite pour
marimba pour vibraphone pardon et
voitures accorde donc voilà c'est ça
donc le vibraphone c est ça ressemble un
peu au marimba succès beaucoup plus
petit et le son est beaucoup plus proche
c'est un étalon n'est pas à moi donc
c'est il ya beaucoup de possibilités de
son jeu vous invite à venir découvrir la
pièce parce que ça ça change vraiment
yen évolution entre le début et la fin
avec les archets qui viennent toucher
les cordes
donc ça aussi c'est très
ça paie le voyage en fait on est
transporté du début jusqu'à la fin dans
un autre univers à la fin mais je trouve
que c'est un peu un voyage dans la
galaxie on aurait fait le reste et donc
ça c'est vrai que c'est une oeuvre a
priori tout peut être une découverte est
là et il a été écrite très très
récemment
donc pour nous c'est important aussi de
d'apporter de la musique qui se fait
aujourd'hui et pas seulement de rester
avec des choses qu'on connaît déjà en
fête et pour nous c'est apporte un autre
éclairage aussi sur la sur notre métier
hun sen tracé poussé un petit peu de
votes quatuor on va en faire un petit
mot maintenant ça fait plus 15 ans que
vous travaillez ensemble et vous êtes 4
je disais tout à l'heure vous êtes
rencontrés au cnsmd paie donc le
conservatoire de musique et de danse de
paris est avec vous il ya nice à yang
qui est au violon et joël martinez au
violoncelle depuis quinze ans toutes les
recharges toujours le quatuor c'est une
source inépuisable je dis toujours que
c'est la quête du graal alors le côté
positif c'est que
on n'a jamais fini on n'est jamais
arrivé
le côté - est positif c'est qu'on n'a
jamais fini on est jamais mais c'est
vrai que on a un tel répertoire
il ya une espèce de perfection d'osmose
qui se crée quand quand ça marche c'est
quelque chose très addictif moi je
trouve il pour avoir fait mieux que
peut-être il conviendra mais beaucoup
beaucoup de musique de chambre dans tous
les domaines du duo jusqu'aux grands
orchestres dans le quatuor est quelque
chose de vraiment particulier qui
s'installe c'est la sorte de la musique
comme il ya quatre mois
c'est vraiment compact et complet
certaine intimité tout en faisant des
oeuvres assez forte où êtes 4,4 voir où
on en fait il ya comme un discours qui
ceux qui s'installent et c'est encore
une le chiffre 4 c'est encore un chiffre
qui permet de chacun être autonome et de
chacun pouvoir apporter sa pierre à
l'édifice de vraiment pouvoir formenté
une interprétation quand on est un grand
groupe il y à il ya plus et plus c'est
plus difficile de faire entendre sa voix
et bien sûr on compte mais à quatre on
doit on peut en tout cas prendre ses
responsabilités et vraiment donner une
ouverture où je veux faire prendre un
chemin en groupe merci à toutes les deux
d'être venu en plateau alors vous jouez
donc au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines demain le
jeudi 1er février
là c'est à 19h30 et si jamais vous ratez
cette date il est aussi les 4 avril et
le 29 mai on est toujours au théâtre sur
la scène nationale parce que c'est du
théâtre cette fois joël pommerat fait
luire vivre de l'intérieur la révolution
française en plaçant les spectateurs au
coeur des débats
ça ira fin de lui est à découvrir du 7
au 10 février
musique encore 50 voix pour un hommage
didier gustin gros donnent de la voix
pour un nouveau spectacle avec as tu
verras claude nougaro rené à travers
différentes voies de la scène française
l'artiste aux trente ans de carrière
était sur la scène de montigny le
bretonneux
[Musique]
jésus
joey starr chante claude nougaro le
match à pessines et didier gustin
l'homme aux cent voire en hommage à
l'artiste dont il est fan faisait partie
des premiers chanteurs que génitales et
c'est aussi le premier chanteur qui est
venu nous voir sur scène en 1987 au
théâtre du tourtour et il m'a dit que
justin tu as trouvé quelque chose
maintenant il te faut creuser
et puis un jour j'ai fait un rêve j'ai
rêvé d'un spectacle qui s'appellerait as
tu verras avec des musiciens avec qui il
vient quelle bonne idée
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui est vraiment
écrivait vraiment très très bien et même
le soir maintenant quand je joue je
découvre encore ses textes et la qualité
de ses textes et la profondeur parce que
vous y tient mais ça il voulait parler
de sa chimie est bien sûr voilà on m'a
dit que je redécouvre les textes le soir
avec as tu verras didier gustin entraîne
dans la maison jadis habité par claude
nougaro 50 invités viennent chercher
l'inspiration d'une mystérieuse
font-elles johnny hallyday eddy mitchell
ou encore raphaël interprète les grands
titres de l'artiste toulousain
j'ai voulu choisir les chansons les plus
connues les plus emblématiques
l'emblématique puis aussi celle que
j'aimais et après on est après j'ai pris
les interprètes pour qui calais avec
dont quatre boules de cuir quelqu'un qui
se bat qui est costaud j'ai mis johnny
bidonvilles bas lavilliers renault où il
faut tourner la page parce qu'il a quand
même tourné une page puisqu'il est
revenu sur scène disparu depuis bientôt
14 ans claude nougaro laisse en héritage
didier gustin l'avait amené avec lui à
montigny le bretonneux
[Musique]
toulouse
elisabeth by a débuté la photographie
par curiosité l'artiste a découvert le
8e art grâce à son père est au travail
argentique ses particularités la prise
de vue naturel et le tirage sur
différents supports comme le textile
elle expose jusqu'au 17 février
conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux
je suis venu sur le textile parce que je
trouve que la photographie elle doit
être vivante en fait on prend du vivant
même si on l'arrête
elle le doit restituer quelque chose qui
se dégage et qui continuent de vivre et
donc le support est très important
propos recueillis par aurélie rose et
quentin le frère elle a tout juste 18
ans et travaille sur son premier rhdp
sahara a été révélée il y a deux ans au
tremplin des voix le concours de chant
organisé à l'estaminet de magny les
hameaux
elle était notre invité l'autre lors de
notre émission de fin d'année écouter
[Musique]
alors de signature
estce des la culture
ah les femmes
[Musique]
m
voilà
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
elles ont machaa
inquiète nos deux noms
[Musique]
classement
m
un coeur ça
[Musique]
mais ce lac du bois
son match à 1
accro demeure non
non
chavez lac du bois
ils ont machin
aken port de masques non
[Musique]
notre place la faiblesse des glaces mais
ce n'est ce pas
[Musique]
zac de bezannes
macha
à cairns post
non
les lacs tôt
moi
à kiel
[Musique]
non
très tôt
mais pour mâchoire
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
étienne votre guitariste alors vous avez
interprété non nothing last c'est votre
tout premier titre qui sont il ya peu si
ça alors je les dodgers avaient sûrement
du temps vous habitez magny les hameaux
mais d'où vous vient cette passion le
chant or de chance c'est une passion
depuis toujours j'ai baigné dans la
musique depuis toute petite ma mère
chantait mon grand-père était dure une
liste donc c'est vraiment ça a toujours
fait partie de ma vie en fait c'est pour
ça que tout jeune dès 2014 vont tenter
the voice et vous êtes aussi finalistes
du concours la voie en scène en 2015 qui
est organisée à magny les hameaux les
concourants ça vous permet de vous faire
connaître aussi un peu c'est ça c'est un
tremplin
ça a permis de faire ce que je fais
aujourd'hui de rencontrer et qui fait
qu'ils travaillent justement ce qu'on
fait c'est un style un peu pop anglaise
vous chantez d'ailleurs la langue de
shakespeare
pourquoi avoir choisi de cette langue là
est peut-être pas le français alors si
ils façon pour moi de m'exprimer qui est
plus un peu le français
sûr que l'anglais comparé aux français
six as et musical déjà de battre quand
on le parle et 6 universités sur tout le
monde ne peut le comprendre
vous avez des références peut-être des
influences des grands artistes où vous
voulez mettre que votre pâte
non j'ai des influences pop uropéenne
que bien de ses génériques au brésil qui
leur fait un peu tous les artistes ils
commencent à émerger en ce moment des
artistes aussi peut-être
que vous écoutez vos parents vous êtes
chez plus petite un peu moins un peu
moins je suis plus des skis actuelle
alors vous avez un ep qui ne devrait pas
tarder à sortir vous êtes en pleine
création
mais pour le moment vous diffusée sur
youtube notamment des petites vidéos une
mais là ce sont des reprises propres
métal djédjé mario way comment voulez
travailler ces artistes un livre qu'ils
ont les travail et donc en bio en fait
on essayait d'un peu de mettre notre
souci de reprendre le morceau crack soit
totalement comme l'original il est vrai
que là donc je me semble plutôt sûr mais
sont à moi ce qui est propre à moi même
en fait et vous avez parlé de quoi dans
votre fenêtre un peu de tout ce que tu
peux ressentir à mon âge déception
lecture un peu tout ce qui touche tout
le monde
vous écrivez vous tout seul vous avez
une plume qui vous suit
alors je commence à écrire moi-même à
être un peu ce que je ressens et c'est
donc laissons la paix vont être une
partie de moi mais notamment la sig là
c'est cédric loïs un ami à qui je
travaille qu'il a produit et qui la
composent est aussi donc il y les
artistes lui si l'un des dix livres donc
je pense qu'il faut aimer noise et sa
merci sarah pourra vous écouter sur
scène le 2 février prochain elle est
séparée de magny les hameaux
cca merci diva phone mêle culture folk
brit pop et électro le jeune groupe
français se produit ce week-end sur la
scène de la batterie de guyancourt un
concert vous pourrez notamment entendre
leur nouveau single déjà dans toutes les
têtes écoute
[Musique]
allah
robespierre victor hugo simone veil lors
discours ont marqué l'histoire de
l'assemblée nationale ses textes sont
repris en une voix celle de joey starr
il était sur la scène du théâtre
montansier de versailles nickel et demi
d'euros et camille lambert l'on
rencontrait pour nous regarder
pas de rap aujourd'hui pour joey starr
mais du théâtre avec son spectacle
éloquence à l'assemblée avec notamment
deux grandes figures historiques
robespierre à lamartine victor hugo
pourquoi ces grandes figures qu'elle
soit pourquoi non c'est surtout le fond
qu'à l'emportant déjà passé pas juste
les figures et puis c'est surtout on
fait quelque chose qui m'a été proposée
par pierre grillet jérémie lippmann et
au départ pierre grillet revisitait tu
ces grands hommes qui ont été et qui ont
fait qu'on est et qui ont fait de la
politique et qui aussi on est artiste de
côté donc voilà il a eu l'idée c'était
un peu plus d'un nom m demain avec les
schémas de mettre ça en scène et me
proposer et c'est important que les
discours sortent des bâtiments
institutionnels
mais bien sûr que c'est sûr important et
comment on avait pu donner le ton dans
le 4 et même des gens qui se déplacent y
sont pas forcément au théâtre parce que
c'est moins et autres vont bien sûr que
c'est important ça ça rime à quoi
c'est l'un des objectifs de la pièce moi
j'ai déjà dit tout ce que je fais je le
fais pour moi je fais pour moi
principalement il parce que ça
m'intéresse c'est parce que voilà après
si les gens convergent dessus c'est
génial mais on part je ne pense pas ce
genre de choses vous savez vous ce qui
est triste c'est que c'est sur le peuple
que pèse la peine de mort vous avez
obligé dites vous isabelle dans un
plateau de la balance ignorance et la
misère
il fallait un contrepoids dans l'autre
plateau vous avez mis la peine de mort
est bien ôter la peine de mort vous va
la forcer forcé entendez-vous de thé
aussi les nuances et la misère vous êtes
condamné à pousser amélioration à la
fois alors le théâtre montansier a été
créé en 1777
est ce que le discours à plus de
résonance ici dans un lieu historique
comme celui là
with lower si on veut quoi mais pour moi
que ce soit que j'ai de jouer à anjou ou
hameaux ou voilà maintenant après
effectivement c'est le premier théâtre
c'est c'est surtout pour moi c'est ce
dont je trouve que c'est surtout on
négocie un flat et puis voilà quoi mais
après après comme je le disais moi ce
qu'il nous ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
tout ça tout ça soit porté le de manière
avérée juste et je veux dire si c'est
une première ici pour vous un versailles
c'est une première pour moi versés et du
coup quel est le discours que vous avez
le plus aimé c'est ça se fait vraiment à
l'humeur ça change en bien sûr j'ai bien
sûr une présentation
ouais ouais ça ce pas l'humeur mais
c'est sûr que j'ai une affection
particulière pour pour aimé césaire par
exemple voilà mais sinon non il faut
savoir que pour certains discours comme
celui d'olympe de gouges qu'elle n'a pas
pu livrer pour d'espn je reste les gens
sont morts le lendemain voire quelques
jours après quoi donc on sent que déjà
on est plus on n'est pas dans la
dynamique du jour d'hui où on a des
énarques qui sont ou des politiciens qui
sont des managers et le privé a pris pas
sûr public d'un nettement alors que on
sent qu'il ya des relents de ça déjà
c'est et paca en 1700 autres mais on
sent qu'il ya plus de militantisme plus
de ventre plus de coeur enfin voilà quoi
et comment fait on se met dans la peau
de ses personnages ses personnages déjà
comme je le disais au départ on peut on
peut et c'est déjà comme je le disais au
départ ce sont des gens c'est des gens
qui contrôlent écrit pour le théâtre ou
qu'on écrit toukourou voilà donc on sent
que dans l'écriture
et que c'est très théâtral même si ça
reste de la politique même s'ils sont là
pour informer annoncé ou imposer aux
autres
il ya quelque chose de cause de très
théâtral déjà donc de fait à part
robespierre qui était avocat voilà que
les autres dont du coup du coup ça du
coup c'est écrit avec avec une certaine
verve en phase
enfin voilà quoi donc donc c'est ce qui
me permet peut-être de trouver une porte
pour pouvoir y accéder
il ya un jour dans l'année où le plus
imperceptibles citoyen où l'attendent
social participe à la vie heymans du
pays tout entier ou la ruse et 3 de
poitrine se dilate allaire vaste des
affaires publiques
un jour le plus faible sans lui la
grandeur de la souveraineté nationale et
l'intégralité de cet entretien est à
retrouver sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme
envie d'une comédie d'action c'est au
cinéma les yeux d'elsa de saint cyr
l'école qu'il faut vous rendre bertrand
pin et vous donne rendez vous écouter
alors le coup de coeur du cinéma les
yeux d'elsa
cette semaine c'est la ressortie en
copie numérique du film les aventures de
jack burton dans les griffes du mandarin
un des films avec le plus long titre
imaginables un film de john carpenter
réalisé en 86 après les grands succès de
john carpenter
il va s'attaquer à ce film qui est une
sorte de comédie d'aventuré très étrange
un film qui sur le papier a toutes les
raisons de bien fonctionner et qui va
être un four total ça va pas marché du
tout kurt russell en est l'acteur
principal c'est une sorte de indiana
jones qui est se rencontreraient les les
guerriers de la montagne magique enfin
ac il ya une aventure du kung-fu des
effets spéciaux de la magie et puis un
héros toujours plus plus bête de d'heure
de minute en minute dans le film il ne
cesse de nous surprendre par son
imbécilité en même temps il est comme
toujours extrêmement attachant donc je
vous invite à venir le voir à partir
d'aujourd'hui au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
et puis vendredi
on fera une ciné-conférence à 20h30
j'aurai le plaisir de vous dire encore
plus de choses sur ce film que j'aime
beaucoup et que j'espère vous viendrez
découvrir chez nous
les comédiens de déclic et théâtre se
lance un défi réinventer le septième art
en direct ce jeudi 1er février ils vont
faire tout un cinéma et improviser des
films plan c est de retour au grenier à
sel de trappes et à la merise une
adaptation celle de roméo et juliette la
célèbre tragédie de shakespeare
jean-philippe duris et une chorégraphie
où se mêlent fame and co et néoclassique
extraits c'est à nous tous cas dos
faites aux femmes est donné c'est la fin
de ce site une culture merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]